about him taking you on a date so like a
really like a really big thing right
like for a lot of girls a lot of modern
women's biggest issue is that most men
don't want to commit or most men they
deal with don't want to commit nowadays
right men commit less today than I did
before but that's because women are
freely having sex outside of commitment
whereas back in the day when the girl
when the woman was like I'm not gonna
have sex with you until I see everyone
on this finger that was the incentive
for me to get married and that's why men
did it so actually dating now well but
what we're trying to say is that when it
comes to the data market it is actually
women who have the power because women
are the choosers did you know and
actually check this as well
um uh but I heard like a stat that you
know only 40 of men have ever reproduced
I've heard that too only 40 of men right
where it's like above 90 of women
because women choose who they have sex
with women choose this is why
competition amongst men right the
masculine competition competition starts
at conception was conception is one egg